he's Jared Payton son of sweetness and
boulders 1979 Porsche 930 turbo
auctioned off live today on NBCSN Jared
good morning how are you I'm doing well
dan how you guys doing we're doing great
so who came up with the idea of
auctioning off dad's Porsche well it is
something that I've been thinking about
for a long time it's something he left
to me and you know he cared about this
car so much Dan and I'm not a car guy
and when it comes down to it I feel bad
looking at it sometimes because I feel
like I don't drive it enough I work so
much now covering you know stuff here in
Chicago for WGN it's it's so hard and
anytime that I have family time I start
my week on Sundays I end on Thursdays
Fridays I'm home with my daughter
sometimes with my son when he gets home
and we hang out Friday's the only day
that we have as a family on Saturday so
there's no time for me to drive it and I
keep looking at it going what what do
you want me to do and I think right now
he's probably looking down on me saying
you haven't told that thing yet you
doing holding on to it what other
memorabilia do you have your dad's
what's the coolest piece of memorabilia
um the things that mean the most to me
are the game worn jerseys and the things
that are priceless you know like the bag
that my dad brought home the last day
from Halas hall with all of his stuff
and it's got tape in there it's got
shoes the old kangaroos like that's the
stuff that means the most to me Dan and
that's the stuff that I'll never ever
give away that's the stuff I want to be
able to pass on to my son to have the
stuff that's me is is priceless on this
car it's an investment when you look at
it and where I'm at right now as a
father as a husband it's not what I'm
looking to invest money and I've and I'm
investing money into it so my goal is to
have somebody out there that will truly
truly love this car and also respect it
and take care of it the same way that my
dad would there's usually a reserve on
cars like this that has to get to a
certain price is there a reserve on this
there's no reserve damn I was on I was
on WGN the other morning and Gus's he
works for me come came up to me was
asking me about what we were going to do
and I'm like I don't know we're gonna
you know do a reserve I feel like when
you put a reserve on that mean say you
have a little bit of control right and I
started thinking about it the camera
went live and I just woke out and go man
breaking news there's no reserve well
and this car this car is going to be
sold actually tomorrow afternoon and
it's slot 134 so pretty cool and once I
said there was no reserve you should
have seen the emails that I was getting
from all over the world famous people
have emailed me that are now in on the
bidding I wish I could tell you who they
are but I told them that I would keep it
quiet but it's gonna be pretty exciting
so I look forward to seeing how the
whole process plays out former teammates
interested in buying this car no I
haven't got any former teammates okay
just people people are just some people
some actors and some famous people have
sent some emails yeah so pretty cool
some I guess if you look at a lot of big
huge Walter Payton fans so if you go out
there and look at some famous actors
that are taking fans you'll probably
figure out who it is I'm thinking Vince
Vaughn is interested in this or Bill
Murray well Bill Murray's not gonna
email you but so wasn't Vince Vaughn
what if what if Mitchell's were Biscay
says I want the car him and I can talk
about a price man he's one of my
favorites he really is he's one of my
favorites so we can figure out and talk
about a price and I still remember when
he was drafted you know by the Bears the
one the first thing when people asked
him who was one of his favorite players
was he said you know he did a lot of
studying on my dad and I think that made
the transition for a lot of Bears fans
here in Chicago pretty happy so if I
offered $100,000 right now do we then
not do the auction on Saturday listen I
know I know what you make man you got to
dig deeper in those sockets actually
what I wanted to do because I told Paul
I wanted to do is actually just take the
car and put
Hinds you would just let you guys kind
of like keep it there a little long and
actually be behind you every single day
but I'd have to take it out and test
drive it I have to do that with all my
cars though Jared oh you know what side
of Chicago we'll make it happen yeah I
can drive it back from Chicago right I
could yeah this is gonna be it six
figures it's probably gonna be in you
know the provenance the fact that it was
your dad bought it new yeah he bought it
on bought it new and so it's his first
sports car it's the last sports car of
his that we still have and you know it
was his baby wait where's the
Lamborghini the rushing remember
Lamborghini well for some reason that
thing kept breaking down back in the day
in the 80s of my dad go fill it up at
O'Hare Airport so he was always like
super upset not being trying to win his
on he had the Ferrari and all that stuff
but this is the one down that stayed
this is the one that left the most and
there's there's so many cool stories I
still remember and my mom's probably
gonna kill me for telling you this I
remember being at a skate park and I was
at a listening to a band and I went
outside this girl it was when I was like
13 years old she had me a cigarette and
she handed to me and I had it in my hand
and I wasn't I didn't know what I was
going to do with it because I didn't
know what to do with it and then as I
was maybe about to go take a drag I look
over to my right and people are like
cool car and my dad is sitting in this
Porsche looking at me and I'll never
forget throwing it down and getting in
the car and him driving homes the one
like a hundred and twenty miles per hour
I was so scared my mom was having a Mary
Kay party with like 60 women at the
house and I came at my house crying
falling out that was like one of those
memorable moments that I had with this
car so it means a lot and I'm just
hoping that somebody gets a chance to
take care of the same way that he would
Obama oh that actually would be a good
one I'm still trying to meet him I never
had a chance to meet him before so I
look forward to it but yeah any of those
guys I would talk a price with you know
Ashton Kutcher ooh
[Music]
he's one that I'm 34 he was first and
foremost he's the guy that I wanted to
get in touch with just because of his
relationship with like the feelings that
he has about my dad but I haven't got
him I saw I was gonna put on yesterday
but you know it's a Chicago connection
Jim Belushi
no even if you guess it I can't all
right all right and Michael Jordan it is
not no Jordans not I actually bought one
of Jordans cars back in the day when I
got to the Tennessee Titans so it's one
of the first purchases that I ever made
wait what did you invent a seven six a
BMW 760 of his a black one I had no
house I had no an apartment I got my
first check with the Tennessee Titans
and I thought I bought a car that I
could have lived in that had a
refrigerator in the back it was it was
on it was unreal unbelievable taller but
you know my life has changed now and
everything now is family-oriented and if
I can't put two car seats in the back of
my hips and my wife doesn't like driving
in it then you know it's time to go and
I'm looking forward to seeing whoever
gets this and some of the pictures that
come along with it and just that feeling
of my dad that the presence that the car
has it's unbelievable it's in great
shape and only under 10,000 miles so
there's not a lot of miles on this car
Jerrod great to talk to you again and I
hope the careers going well and good
luck with the auction tomorrow thank you
guys thanks for having me that's so
Jarrod Peyton his dad of course Walter
Payton the auction will be it starts
today
but the car will be auctioned off
tomorrow on NBCSN for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
you